shout out tonight for someone who is not
a journalist but has helped set a tone
of erudite resistance in an era when
attacks on journalists have come from
many directions but none more ugly than
from the White House this is someone who
works at what the president calls the
failing and New York Times my name is
David McLeod I am the deputy general
counsel at the New York Times Company
and my primary responsibility is
anything that comes out of the newsroom
that presents a legal problem David
McCoy has never won a Pulitzer Prize or
even had a New York Times byline but I
told him that in newsrooms around the
country he is seen as a hero in an era
of journalism under attack I'm not sure
I'm gonna buy into the hero label but
certainly I've had a platform to stand
up for journalism and I'm proud to do
that it has put him head-to-head with
Donald Trump the New York Times is
totally dishonest totally dishonest I
think the main thing that concerns me
has been the attempt by the President
and others to delegitimize the press it
really is an invitation to distrust to
not believe you are fake news you are
the enemy of the people you look at the
network so you look at the news you look
at the newscasts I call it fake news I
draw a line between that and criticism
with the press press should be
criticized any institution should but
this idea of just to dismiss it as fake
news enemy the people I think has been
deadly do you think Donald Trump
believes that I think he knows that it
plays well to a political base I don't
know whether he really thinks that is a
true fact and the New York Times is
failing if I weren't here I believe the
New York Times probably wouldn't even
exist when he continues to refer to the
time there's the failing New York Times
what's the reaction inside this building
it's a little amusing because as you
know he also talks about how he saved
the New York Times because subscriptions
went through the roof when he was
elected and that's really closer to the
truth in his new book truth in our times
McCrory calls perhaps his finest hour as
he came to the defense of the New York
Times report about two women
claim Trump had physically groped them
he was like an octopus it was like he
had six arms he was all over the place
Trump than a candidate annually denied
the allegation
now we address the slander and libel
that was just last night thrown at me by
the Clinton machine and the New York
Times and other media outlets as part of
a concerted coordinated and vicious
attack and overnight Trump's lawyer
demanded the Times retract its story and
issue an apology saying quote failure to
do so will leave my client with no
option but to pursue all available
actions and remedies I felt that we
needed to have a strong response the
response was this letter from the craw
no retraction essentially see you in
court we did what the law allows we
publish newsworthy information about a
subject of deep public concern if mr.
Trump disagrees if he believes that
American citizens had no right to hear
what these women had to say and the law
of this country forces us and those who
would dare to criticize him to stand
silent or be punished we welcome the
opportunity to have a court set him
straight
the letter went viral in the end I think
the people two times were very happy
that I'd done it this way and I'm
fortunate to work in a company that was
going to stand behind me for a response
is strong so our shout out tonight for
David McCraw defender of the First
Amendment that's our program for tonight
thanks for joining us we'll see you back
here next week good night